welcome chair Powell thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon
thank you Nick it's a pleasure to be
here and I want to welcome our audience
watching Along on wsj.com Twitter and
YouTube so chair Powell let's get
started two years ago you acted very
quickly and decisively uh you did things
that fed chairs straight up have not
done given the emergency of the pandemic
now I hear a lot today especially from
our readers they look at the economy
they look at how high inflation is and
they look at the state of monetary
policy and they say the FED is not
reacting with the same urgency what do
you say to people who say that you are
not treating High inflation today like
an emergency
well I guess I would start by saying
this Nick that um we know that this is a
time for us to be tightly focused on the
path ahead and on getting inflation back
down to two percent we know how uh how
people are suffering from high inflation
and we have both the tools and the
resolve to uh to get inflation back down
uh and no one should doubt our resolve
in doing that and uh I I think if you if
you look at uh how quickly we've moved
in the last few months really uh then
you'll you'll see that Financial
conditions have tightened quite a bit
what we need to see is inflation coming
down in a clear and convincing way and
we're going to keep pushing until we see
that
so to get into some of those tactics the
FED raised interest rates at its last
meeting by a half percentage point that
is something the FED hadn't done since
2000 and you've said that you think the
FED may need to do that again at your
next two meetings why are you being so
specific doesn't that limit your options
well I I didn't say uh
so we make the decisions at the meetings
what I said was a couple things first I
said that that we decided to raise the
federal funds rate range for the federal
funds rate by 50 basis points at the
last meeting we also said that we
thought ongoing rate increases would be
appropriate and during the course of the
meeting it became clear that there was
very broad support on the committee for
uh
for having on the table the idea of
doing additional rate increases of that
magnitude at each of the next two
meetings and that's what I said and uh
you know that's not that's short of of a
prediction or or a statement that
forward guidance that we're actually
going to do this but I would say if the
economy performs about as we expect then
that's that's something that'll be on
the table and honestly it's it's so
things are so uncertain in the economy
right now it's very difficult to think
about trying to give guidance uh out
into the future
um we we don't know uh the path of the
economy there are many Global events
going on that can affect that that are
really not under our control as well so
if if the base case is to do a half
point of the next two meetings why not
just do a percentage point at your next
meeting you know rip the Band-Aid off
well as you know inflation Works through
sorry uh monetary policy Works through
expectations so markets are pricing in
uh a series of significant series of
future rate hikes amounting to them to
already having done that so uh so we um
you know we like to work through
expectations and I'm not blessing any
particular day's readings but it's been
it's been good to see uh financial
markets reacting in advance uh based on
on on the the way we're speaking about
the economy and the consequence as I
mentioned is that Financial conditions
overall have tightened significantly I
think that you know if you broadly
across Financial conditions you're
seeing that and that's what we need what
we need is to see really uh growth
moving down from the very high levels
that we saw last year
moving down to a level that's still
positive but that will give the supply
side a chance to catch up and a chance
for inflation to come down as we as we
get supply and demand back in uh you
know back together
a couple years ago you talked about
moving slowly when you're in a dark room
when the lights go out obviously things
are different now it's harder to do that
you're moving in much faster increments
as you raise the the price of overnight
money but I wonder as you look ahead
what are you going to be looking for to
determine whether to increase that pace
of half percentage Point increases say
to three quarters of a point or to slow
things down to the quarter point
increment by which the FED has raised
interest rates more often over the last
couple of decades
so I I do think um you know by the
standards of uh Central Bank practice in
recent decades we're moving about as
fast as we've moved in in several
decades
um but I I guess the way I would say it
is this what we need to see is clear and
convincing evidence that inflation
pressures are abating and inflation is
coming down
and if we don't see that then then we'll
have to consider moving more
aggressively if we do see that then we
can consider moving to a slower pace
and it's going to be a judgment call
that we make going forward as we as we
carefully monitor incoming data the
evolving Outlook how are Financial
conditions changing how are they
affecting the economy and uh that's how
I think about it
so so back in 2016 uh you were a
governor of the FED uh and in late 2018
uh you were chair of the FED there was a
significant tightening in financial
conditions there were some Global growth
shocks uh Global growth was slowing and
the FED pulled back from its plans to
raise rates maybe as aggressively as as
would have been the case before all that
happened with the global shocks that
we're facing now the recent tightening
and financial conditions that we're
seeing now what would what would you
need to see on that side of the markets
to reassess the pace of rate increases
right now
you know the the underlying uh strength
of the U.S economy is is is really good
right now the United the US economy is
strong the labor market is extremely
strong uh growth this year has been
marked down but is still at very healthy
levels so you saw today's retail sales
number uh the economy is strong the
consumer consumer balance sheets are
healthy businesses are healthy uh the
banks are well capitalized so this is a
strong economy and uh I we think it's
well positioned to withstand less
accommodative monetary policy tighter
monetary policy
um we of course we do monitor Global
events and Global events have been very
important drivers of economic conditions
lately the war in Ukraine uh is
something that has upset the global
commodity picture while also threatening
the global order more broadly and the
rolling shutdowns in China uh are still
going on and those are those are having
an effect on Global Supply chains of the
course so we watch those things we watch
how they affect the US economy the
effects are very uncertain they they
probably weigh on growth downward on
growth and probably push inflation up at
the margin but even through all that we
see the U.S economy continuing to show
real strength and be well positioned to
handle the the uh the policy changes
that we're making
chair Powell a number of your former
colleagues Richard Clarita who was vice
chair until this past January Bill
Dudley the former New York fed president
uh have said recently that they think
that the FED is going to have to raise
its short-term policy rate to three and
a half percent maybe four percent maybe
higher
are you thinking about the destination
right now uh for how high you might have
to raise interest rates
so as a policy maker
um the way I'm thinking about it is that
right now we're raising rates um
uh expeditiously to what we've been
saying to a more normal level which is
uh something that will reach maybe in
the fourth quarter but it's not a
stopping point it's not a looking around
point we don't we don't know with any
confidence where neutral is we don't
know where tight is we just don't and
particularly in this environment of
higher inflation and very strong growth
in a really tight labor market so what
we're going to what we're going to be
looking at meeting my meeting data
reading by data reading is uh you know
what's happening with financial
conditions and what's happening with
with the economy really with you know
with the with what the effect what
effects are are changes in policy having
on the economy are we starting to see
what we need to see which is a really
clear and convincing uh evidence that uh
inflation is is coming down that's what
we really need to see so we'll be
watching for that if that involves
moving past
you know broadly understood levels of
neutral we won't hesitate at all to do
that we won't and uh honestly we'll just
we will go until we feel like we're at a
place where we can uh where we can say
yes Financial conditions are an
appropriate place we see inflation
coming down we'll we'll go to that point
and uh there won't be any you know
hesitation about that
just as it can be hard for you to know
when to stop raising interest rates it
can be hard to know when to start and
you know obviously these things look
blindingly obvious in hindsight but I
want to go back to last year and ask you
what went wrong last year from a policy
perspective again with the benefit of
hindsight knowing things now that you
didn't know then what do you wish you
had done differently last year
so we have to make these decisions and
we do make them in real time based on
what we know at the time and so I would
say if you replay last summer
um we had a real spike in inflation that
began in March March April May June of
last year and then inflation came down
month after month after month for about
four months anyway through the end of
the summer so we were we were concerned
because we saw inflation spreading more
broadly and because we didn't see
supply chain uh issues improving we
didn't see labor force participation so
we had real concerns but still the
incoming inflation data we're kind of
consistent with our with our story and
then the data really changed that really
uh changed uh pretty thoroughly
beginning in in October and we responded
very much to that so since then we you
know we pivoted in our policy and since
then you've seen really quite
significant tightening in financial
conditions I don't know that Financial
conditions have tightened more quickly
than this in a very long time and
um but that's what happened and you know
I I I've said and I've said for
the last two and a half months I've been
I've been
saying that if you look back in
hindsight give yourself 2020 hindsight
then yes it probably would have been
better to have raised rates earlier
um we were looking at some week uh weak
employment reports we were looking at at
inflation reports that were coming down
when that stopped and when the data when
the data started pointing towards toward
a stronger economy with higher
inflationary pressures higher wage
pressures we didn't hesitate from that
point we've really moved um
you know I would say almost
expeditiously since then we have moved
and and you see where we are six months
later since that happened you now you
now have the 10 years up you know 140
basis points the the the two years up
almost 200 basis points and the two-year
treasury is a pretty good measure of of
uh policy expectations so quite a lot of
tightening inappropriately so inflation
is way too high uh and we need to bring
it down and we're going to use our tools
to do that
obviously the pandemic has made economic
forecasting more difficult and it's been
in a long time and I wouldn't I wouldn't
presume to think that it's easy but
looking at demand last year the fiscal
stimulus that was approved by the
administration and Congress last March
it was far larger than what Euro and
economists of the FED were anticipating
did that end up putting the FED behind
the curve in terms of uh you just didn't
judge demand properly because of uh the
much larger stimulus that was approved
so I it's really not our role in uh
Economic Policy within the government to
reach judgments on economic actions
taken by by Congress or by the uh by the
administration there are other parts of
the government that do that exact thing
but it's really us so I guess I would
say that
um
there was a lot of stimulus put behind
the US economy that was both monetary
policy and that was fiscal policy but
still you can't you you can't get the
kind of inflation that we've gotten out
of that much demand that was a lot of
support for demand you can't get the
kind of inflation we have without these
Supply bottlenecks that we've had and
that that includes
um you know the supply chain problems
that we've had in the shortages you know
if you look at automobiles that's a
great case ordinarily car makers would
have just made more cars there was
tremendous demand for cars but for you
know really idiosyncratic set of reasons
there weren't enough semiconductors so
there aren't cars and so you have
tremendous vehicle inflation that's just
one example
same thing we didn't see uh you know the
late we had a real um uh hit to labor
force participation we didn't see that
coming and so really these supply side
factors you have to add them in to any
kind of economic model to get the kind
of inflation that we have we clearly had
very strong demand and we knew that what
we didn't know and anticipate was how
large the supply side effects would be
and how persistent they were and we now
know that in hindsight and we see how
sticky they are and so as I've mentioned
you know we're we're now not we're not
setting policy on the expectation that
we get relief on a supply side until we
actually do
all right so that was 2021 then comes
along three months ago the war in
Ukraine uh which has obviously been
enormously disruptive uh to millions of
people uh in Eastern Europe but also uh
has had a profound effect on energy
markets uh commodity markets and uh and
we also have new lockdowns in China how
have those events changed the difficulty
of what it is that you are trying to do
well I mean clearly they've they've
raised the degree of difficulty for more
importantly for the people around the
world who are looking for to have a
continued expansion in the economy but
also for for us from the standpoint of
policy so you know the war in Ukraine uh
is pushing up commodity prices for both
food and energy
and we the thing we don't really know
how long that's going to last now uh we
we it might have thought at the
beginning and we you know we don't make
those kind of judgments that it wouldn't
be long lasting now it looks like it may
be so that may be a persistent effect
same thing with the with the uh the
rolling shutdowns in China they won't
last forever
um but
um they'll last for some time and
they're having an effect too and what
they're doing is they're they're
preventing any um any healing
uh of supply chain problems so uh that's
going to make it harder for for
inflation to come down uh and so really
they've added to the degree of
difficulty and to what was already a
challenging project
so we heard here before lunch from Barry
Biffle the CEO of Frontier Airlines he
says he's raising prices because of fuel
costs and there's a pilot shortage and
now those are things outside of your
control but you said just now that the
FED can no longer set policy on the Hope
or expectation that Supply chains will
will give you a lot of help here so what
does that mean for fed policy if these
things are out of your control in the
supply chain or if energy markets don't
improve anytime soon what is the
implication of that for policy
well doesn't have much of an implication
in the near term because we clearly have
a job to do on demand so and there
there's an imbalance in the economy
broadly between demand and supply and uh
so we can't really affect Supply the
things that are really the supply side
issues our policies don't don't work on
those but we have a job to do on demand
and I would for example point to the
labor market where there are there's
more demand for workers than there are
people available to work by a
substantial margin and so that means
that wages are moving up which is a
great thing but they're moving up at a
pace that is not consistent with two
percent inflation
so there's a pathway for us to to use
our tools to uh to to try to moderate
demands Still Still to a positive level
but not not at the high level that it
was at for example last year and and try
to get demand and Supply back a lot into
alignment in the labor market or close
to it so that there'll still be positive
wage increases uh and you know healthy
wage increases but they'll be at a level
that is more consistent with two percent
inflation wages are very important
um determiner of inflation over the
longer term so that's just an example of
what what our job is and we think we can
do that job in the meantime of course
we're looking for everyone is looking
for uh for the supply side to heal more
we don't see much evidence of that yet
but I mean I still think in the longer
run that has to be coming there will be
semiconductors and uh
and and other other things that are in
short supply right now
a lot of people though are skeptical
that you can get inflation down to your
two percent goal uh without a recession
what what do you know that they don't
I don't know anything that they don't I
mean I I would say it's there's no
disagreement here really it is it is a
going to be a challenging task and it's
been made more challenging in the last
couple of months because of global
events
um so it's challenging because
unemployment is very low already and
because uh inflation is very high and so
but but I will just say there's a there
are Pathways we
clearly there are Pathways for us to to
be able to moderate demand get demanded
Supply back in alignment and get
inflation back down while also can while
also having a strong labor market
doesn't mean that the unemployment rate
needs to remain 3.6 percent which is
very very low rate historically low it's
one tenth above the 50-year low you'd
still have a quite a strong labor market
if inflation if sorry if unemployment
were to move up a few ticks so I would
say there's a there's a you know there
are a number of plausible paths to
having a soft door as I've said softish
landing and you know our job isn't to
handicap the odds it is to try to
achieve that
the last thing I'll say though is that
um
achieving price stability restoring
price stability is is an unconditional
need with something we have to do
because really the economy doesn't work
for for workers or for businesses or for
anybody without price stability so
it's the Bedrock of the economy really
and and so that's something we need to
do if we want to have the kind of labor
market that we all want to have which is
one where there are tight labor market
conditions and wages are moving up and
people are changing jobs and opportunity
is growing and all of that but but
inflation is not high and and eating up
people's paychecks so chair pal I heard
you refer to a softish landing and I
want to ask I mean what's the difference
between a soft landing and a softish
landing because if the pilot tells me
don't worry we're going to have a
softish landing I I don't know I start
to wonder what he's talking about
well so you fly around you know
sometimes the landing is just perfect
right and and sometimes it's just a just
a little bumpy and so it's still a good
Landing you know you don't even notice
it right so but in this what does it
mean in this setting so I I guess I
would say this uh we we have to get
inflation down to two percent we've got
to restore you know our definition of
price stability and and we will do that
um it will be challenging to do that uh
without we have to slow growth to do
that that's that's the idea is that
growth has to move down part that's what
has to happen for inflation to come down
we don't have Precision Tools we don't
we can't say let's let's dial it into
this exact level you know we raise
interest rates that affects Financial
conditions and financial conditions
affect the economy so there are a couple
of steps there and it's not it it is not
in any way a surgically Precision set of
tools so
um I I would say there could as I
mentioned there there could be some pain
involved into restoring
price stability but we think we can
maintain a strong labor market defined
as you know a labor market where
unemployment is low and wages are moving
up and that kind of thing it may not be
the perfect labor market but it will be
a strong labor market so I'll move on
from this subject but I just I want to
ask if there's a historical example that
you could point to for what you're
trying to achieve some people talk about
the late 1990s but even then the
unemployment rate continued to to drift
lower
after the FED raised interest rates so
is is this something that we have any
recent historical experience with what
you're trying to do here
well so you can look back uh to 1960
there have been 11 tightening cycles and
in none of those cycles does it do they
look anything like the current cycle
we've never I don't I don't I won't say
never but I'm not aware of a time when
we've had two job openings for every
unemployed person
and uh it's it's just an extraordinary
it's a Once in a century pandemic
followed by historically large fiscal
and monetary policy support followed by
a war in the middle of Europe between
two commodity makers followed by partial
shutdown of
of you know China
very large economy that's that's the
manufacturing center one of the
manufacturing centers of the world so
can you look in the history book and
find that no you can't and uh so I I
just think we're gonna we're in a world
of firsts so I I wouldn't say just
because it's never happened before it's
impossible I wouldn't say that I would
say that there are plausible paths and
that this will be challenging but we'll
we'll do our best to achieve it in any
place we will achieve price stability
so so what are you looking to see either
in inflation or in financial conditions
that tells you that things are moving in
your direction because it feels like
there's a chance here that inflation
does come down in the second half of the
Year even though it'll still be above
your target but there's also a chance
that the labor market tightens even more
and I wonder how you would uh you know I
know it's hard to respond to a
hypothetical but that doesn't seem like
a crazy hypothetical to be to be
considering right now a situation where
you do get Improvement on inflation but
you do continue to overshoot an estimate
of what might be considered a more
stable employment situation
well the main thing is to get is to get
inflation down you know we all read of
course everyone reads the inflation
reports very carefully and and looks for
uh you know details that look positive
and that kind of thing but truthfully we
don't this is not a time for
tremendously nuanced readings of
inflation we need to see inflation
coming down in a convincing way that's
what we need to see and until we see
that we're you know we're gonna we're
gonna keep going we're not gonna We're
Not Gonna assume that we've made it
until we see that and we're not seeing
that right now we are there there are
some promising signs you can point to
them there are some signs that are not
promising but really that's that's what
we're looking to see so you know with
the policy rate where it is you don't
need to I mean which what we need to do
is is push ahead with rate increases and
and you know make the evaluation that I
mentioned earlier is it is this the
right level should we slow down should
we speed up I think that's what we'll be
doing as we as we see incoming data and
uh and and make a judgment about where
are we have we gotten as far as we need
to get and until we do we'll keep going
now a number of people have suggested to
me that the one thing that might slow
you down or at least make this much more
difficult would be some kind of Market
cataclysm and I wonder in part if that's
why you're trying to be more transparent
uh not erratic making sudden moves on on
your policy moves but my question there
is where's your level of concern that
Financial stability and controlling
inflation by raising interest rates may
be a lot might be fundamentally
incompatible
in that raising rates causes Financial
disruption but doesn't actually bring
inflation under control where is your
level of concern around that situation
but I don't see that happening I mean we
so we monitor a very broad range of
financial conditions and uh we're doing
that now we'll keep doing that and you
know they're different different cycles
look different sometimes the tightening
takes place in one market sometimes in
another sometimes in credit spread
sometimes in all of them so we're
watching them all you know as a group
and I you know it's of course
um their volatility has been up a little
bit and that has that has some effect on
liquidity in some markets but
nonetheless the markets are orderly
they're functioning I think they're
processing uh the way we're thinking the
way that the fomc is thinking about
policy pretty well and um and I think
that the you know the the idea again is
to have Financial conditions tightened
to the point where growth will moderate
and still be positive
but moderate to the point where supply
and demand can get back in alignment and
where we can get inflation back down to
two percent and I you know I see that
broadly working working pretty well
right now obviously there are some
volatile days involved in markets but so
far uh I I I see it as I see us as as
getting through this fairly well
so this is the future of everything
Festival uh and in the time we have left
I want to look ahead at some of the
issues on the horizon for the economy
labor shortage I wonder if you see that
as something that might be a more
persistent uh rather than just a
cyclical feature in our economy I mean
if you look at net immigration since
2017 because of policy reasons for the
pandemic it's been basically flat our
labor shortages here to stay and and
what would the implications of that be
for the Fed
I think there is a risk that will have a
persistent
imbalance between supply and demand in
the labor market and you put your finger
on it it's it's uh it's it's part of its
population there's the labor force
there's the there's the labor force
participation rate but if the population
is growing more slowly they're going to
be fewer workers and that's a that's a
big part of the story really in recent
years is immigration has been quite low
these are not tools that or things that
that the FED has or places where we seek
to guide policy but if you have a slower
um if you have a slower growing labor
market you're going to have a smaller
economy and um you're gonna have you
could be in a position in a situation
where where these wage pressures uh
remain longer of course we'd love to see
labor for labor force participation come
up but I I do think that it's a I think
that's a risk in the medium term but
it's really one for other policy makers
to uh
to look after
and related to that you know economists
have this concept called the natural
rate of unemployment the idea that the
when the economy is finally balanced
there's a level of unemployment that
corresponds with stable inflation and I
went back and looked when you joined the
Board of Governors almost exactly 10
years ago uh you know the the
participants at once a quarter project
where they think these things are and so
in 2012 you and most of your colleagues
thought that that level was between five
and six percent now you and your
colleagues think have been you know
writing down that it's somewhere between
three and a half and the low four
percent area uh but how much weight do
you put on the prospect that the natural
rate of unemployment perhaps temporarily
perhaps not has actually shifted higher
and might be closer to where you and
your colleagues thought it was 10 years
ago
well no I think I think that may well be
right I I think you're um there there
was a tremendous amount of turbulence in
the labor market and so you know in
theory the the sort of matching function
that is the labor market could be
disrupted people are changing jobs at
all-time record rates and uh there's
just a lot going on people are
reevaluating their commitment to the
labor force so all of that points to a
higher natural rate of unemployment but
but you know the the other thing that's
clear though is that the effective
natural rate changes during can change
pretty significantly over the course of
an expansion particularly a long
expansion like the last one where you
you finally had three and a half percent
unemployment and no sign of either wage
or Price inflation but you had you had a
couple of years there where unemployment
was well below four percent and you
didn't see inflation so that that
suggests that as that longest expansion
in recorded US History 10 years and
eight months as that went on what you
saw was matching getting better and
better and better and more efficient and
the natural rate coming down right now
it feels like it feels like the the the
um the actual unemployment rate is is
not the perfect now you have you have to
think about where the where the where
the unemployment where the natural rate
is compared to today's employment rate
and it does appear to me that it's it's
probably well above 3.6 but it should
shift down as this highly unusual time
in our economy and in our labor market
um goes on it should you know we should
see that settling down and we should see
the natural rate declining and that
itself could reduce uh wage pressures
and inflation pressures well all things
equal then I mean would you as the
chairman of the FED feel more
comfortable today if the unemployment
rate or a little bit higher somewhere uh
in the fours instead of in the threes
you know I'm I'm never going to say that
more people need to be out of work
um you know I I would I would love to
see uh uh a labor market that's more in
balance and ideally that would start
with uh with the with the number of
vacancies coming down
and that that's one of the things that
that is vacancies and quits are at
all-time highs and and that that
suggests a labor market that's out of
balance and they're just there's more
demand than there are workers so I'd
love to see people come back into the
labor force and we are seeing some of
that we'd like to see that continue and
we'd like to see the vet job vacancies
level come down so that you're seeing
supply and demand get back together
and um you know the unemployment rate
will shake out where it needs to be it's
as I mentioned it's close to a 50-year
low right now
moving from sort of the post-pandemic uh
labor market to the supply chain and
inventory management it seems much more
possible than it did a year ago that
we're going through a big shift in how
businesses manage the supply chain and
the forces of the last 25 years that
really helped central banks keep
inflation low uh businesses pricing and
efficient uh supply chain now might you
know you might want resilience you might
want to Source goods from multiple
suppliers that could embed uh higher
costs so what would be the implications
for the FED if we're going through some
kind of regime shift where those forces
that helped bring prices down over the
last three decades are reversing now
so I do think you've you've had sort of
a perfect storm of disinflationary
forces for the last quarter century and
that's globalization you know Amplified
by technology it's aging population
certainly in in the western democracies
and all all of that has at low
productivity that is all led to to
disinflation and so some have been
making the argument for years now that
those forces were all going to flip I
don't think they would flip overnight
but I would say you know certainly in
the near term there is a real
possibility that will the globalization
will go into reverse to some extent and
you know the trade-off would be those
those those Supply chains were very
efficient but they weren't very robust
and they they you know they broke down
pretty badly in the in the pandemic so I
mean
to the extent you do that you'd have
more Security in your supply chain more
stability perhaps but it might not be it
might not be quite as efficient as the
amazing Global Supply chains that we had
which were very very fast and and
flexible and all that so I don't I'm not
sure what the overall book you could see
higher inflationary pressures for a time
but at the same time policy could
respond to that so I don't know that
that you see higher inflation
um
so it's it's hard to say globalization
obviously brought
its its costs and its benefits and you
know it benefited lots of parts of the
world uh and um and from our standpoint
we got a lot of products cheaper but our
manufacturing base in in the west is
vastly diminished
and um you know you're right it would be
a very different world if if we see that
go into reverse or pause
uh we're almost out of time I'm going to
try to sneak in one last question to you
you were confirmed last week to a new
four-year term uh with significant
bipartisan support someone joked to me
you see that sort of support only to
adjourn the Senate these days
um you've been through a lot in your
first four years as fed share especially
in the last two is there anything you've
learned in that time that might change
your approach to this job in the next
four years
um you know I I
think that there's an overwhelming need
to get inflation under control and
that's what I'm thinking about that's
what we're thinking about here at the
Fed
um in times when you know you're at two
percent inflation and the economy is
growing and unemployment's really low
uh you can you can have a more balanced
you know thought about what you should
be doing at work I think we know what we
need to be doing at work right now which
is which is to get inflation under
control and we'll use our tools to do
that that's that's my dominant thought
about the future at the FED it's a great
honor to to be to to be able to serve a
second term and of course I'll do my
very best
you know to carry out our obligations
under the Dual mandate and uh
leave it there well chair Powell thank
you so much for joining us this
afternoon it's an honor to have you with
us
and thank you to our audience on
wsga.com and Twitter and YouTube for
joining us this afternoon